le 9 mai c'est la journée de l'europe
depuis maintenant 1985
l'occasion pour le député jean-frédéric
poisson de se rendre au lycée
professionnel jacques prévert de
versailles devant une centaine de
lycéens
il y a tenu une conférence pour partager
sa vision de l'europe
la france a besoin des générations qui
viennent que rappeler à ces jeunes gens
et jeunes filles que dans quelques
années c'est eux qui auront les clés il
faudra veiller à ce que l'héritage le
plus précieux que nous avons reçus des
générations précédentes c'est-à-dire
notre civilisation et la paix soient
transmises et qu'ils aient la volonté de
transmettre cet héritage non l'europe un
enjeu crucial pour ce lycée qui propose
des sections européennes et envoie
chaque année 10 de ses élèves effectuent
un stage en immersion de quatre semaines
en espagne
nos élèves ont déjà la possibilité de
suivre une section européenne en
espagnol et moi même j'ai la possibilité
d'enseigner la matière professionnelle
en anglais et nous souhaitons vraiment
développer les langues étrangères pour
nos élèves afin de faciliter encore
leur recherche de travail à la sortie du
bac après la conférence place à la
remise des diplômes europa ce certificat
atteste d'une expérience professionnelle
à l'étranger des séjours que ces lycéens
en terminale ne sont pas prêts d'oublier
on apprend à être plus responsables avec
plus autonome on est quand même un peu
livrés à nous mêmes
pendant un mois c'est vraiment quelque
chose que j'attendais depuis des années
c'était d'avoir une expérience
professionnelle en espagne et je
regrette rien je regrette pas d'être
parti depuis 2013 une quarantaine de
lycéens ont réalisé des stages à
salamanque en espagne l'année prochaine
changement de destination direction
séville